rainbows
[Applause]
pretty good shot this reason an affair
this is my speed ahead the Jose Ramon
green threads the needle and Jones with
his first bucket hits have left through
these two teams little bit lighting it
up
draymond Green gets a good look now at
the make it a two-point game innocent
had curry with KB came to help that was
awful dream on foot
[Applause]
[Music]
doesn't a just shot at the last second
he anticipated defensively got that
position hooker got off balanced
officially part two of their last 13
after starting 10 of those teams steal
by draymond two-on-one date the dollars
on the way and operate will finish it
off ending in the first half
there is the former defensive players a
year and still in the very elite and
stopping and then start shot clock
a mob thought about that three
[Applause]
to close the half he's moving and then
he feet slipped out from under expose
three-point range by maybe fifteen of
points
[Music]
hitting that flippers last night tonight
here at Golden State than Portland on
Friday and then they'll finish up in
Denver on Sunday green with the block
six point swing he's 35% but when
someone's open they're a lot better on
the return form a basket you can't work
and you're sitting and waiting to rehab
and get better that's a terrific pass
that is an absolutely gorgeous pass
leading curry to the basket bility to
pass the ball and Harris never saw the
ball had his back to the passer from
dream on two men jumping staff the lavas
perfectly followed by draymond Green
Looney read the play equally well and a
fun matchup as these two teams face off
for the very first time this season
draymond Green with the steal off a bad
pass from Lonzo ball Kevin Durant's
first shot of the night this good to
think why they posting him up against
Kevin Durant but he uses size of shrimp
draymond Green at the basket board so
the thought was that there you see
Engram come in and shove Duran
[Applause]
beautifully done his step foot spit and
the Warriors have tied the game
[Music]
[Applause]
in the corner that is it
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's also a contract year for and Willie
cauley-stein she's 53 percent from the
field and 53 percent from the lunch
there's dream on driving again so one
drive yielded the loonie Tiffany left
open not when he goes to the rim playing
your Hannah felt inside Alex with
Iguodala missing that three Raymond's
decision that's very poor defense about
putting 48 minutes together even a
championship team used to focus on the
details exactly play cutting bake
toothbrush their batteries about 100
miss any more games if he has to
[Applause]
urban behind-the-back Horford able again
it drives one knocked out of his hands
by draymond Green
cousins all beautiful bounce pass
percussive Porter played about six
minutes in beat poked in away with a
shot clock at two now Brewer on the
break Kluwer clean four tries to go
Coast and Coast and here's the block
shot five-point game six minutes to go
here curry lays it in with the left for
his first field goal his 13th minute
play largest lead of the night for
Golden State and then another turnover
that's the ninth live ball turnover
curry great
[Applause]
they as leaders right now wide open
breathe to the guy like dream I was able
to grab it off the rim and push it so
Chetan idea
the man had the rim for the monster
though it's not about being outplayed
you are being thoroughly outwork right
now make the adjustment
draymond Green against Gerald Green cata
an avowal points off turnovers got to
favor I'm sorry
shot clock down to three this simple
drive and dream on the dunk and the foul
how about that block there by draymond
Green
Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
he knows how to get airspace to shoot
the ball that's the theory and I stop
touch shooting and fans very instigated
like tight
instead
[Music]
[Applause]
Steff knocked away from that vehicle
[Applause]
brain cut got around Drummond it's an
open dream on
[Applause]
lead of the game is right now hosts most
all-star break he's been hitting threes
so he has him when you work hard you
make care of things and one half court
two seconds left the rats got the seal
[Applause]
dream on the early seal by Kady you know
they gotta play boys let's do things
against his team in there doing on the
guys that got playoff experience so that
is a factor than the mine say see
draymond again the defensive Tencent
intensity but can finish in the paint as
well Alex Caruso fourth-year player
Texas alone takes it on green he knocks
it away with a block right there
here comes Trayvon the other way ready
three blocks here I managed it couldn't
quite catch up he thought he's gonna get
it but dream on flipping it up and in to
drawing the foul
dance he has the ball in his right hand
he comes in here we've draws the foul
then goes back to the left hand he draws
the foul holding two hands on the ball
okay and they get strong that way and
then he releases jam it got his own
rebound
that's a breakdown for the Warriors and
have the shooter get a missed free throw
he's an alert basket I'm sure every like
that rayvon
knocked it away save the day positive
he's learning how to score inside poison
six minutes cream ugly the steel I think
Thank You Raymond over William who's
second shot at Temple what an impressive
year he's had mark doc talked about her
great feat event by
full wide-open Fremont grant dozens
again letting him shoot look how they
call from nice feed inside cousins who's
a good passing big man
Marcus cousins hey Darrin him the shoot
will come a time where he's going to
step in rhythm with confidence but right
now patience allows the play to develop
delivers the basketball and draymond
Green put the finish and the content
move out cousins
that's Mizzou boss is gonna get used to
the playoffs you're like this
[Applause]
[Music]
sooo bots can't hold on and here comes
three as top sit on the way away is back
in it just sit on the side and chair no
time for technicals on the side
the ball getting the play call and
filing Beverly out and on the other end
great to have you so funny is listening
to Steve Kerr has green misses the
layout encourages anguishing over this
team and he's got such a great team as
green gives it up all play making at its
best Curry's thinking two-for-one right
here you're the Clippers you got to be
aggressive draymond Green goes right at
Harold speed draymond green sets the
screen dives to the cuff him
that was a bad race did you expect
anything I did I expected a good race
for Durant
yet the offensive in has a smaller
defender on them takes them right into
the post and flexing may break their
starting lineup they're vulnerable
because their bench has severe
limitations that's a face move from
draymond Green goes right at cappella
curry
to the pivot foot green tries to freeze
that's good
draymond Green from downtown
he had missed 16 three-pointers in a row
onto that pivot foot
you got the pass off there's that
two-step oh he's on his tiptoes
but shuffles the pass out green a rare
three-pointer we head Tilton was the top
scoring first quarter team but in this
series as we said it's pinned the
Warriors step back three try knocked
away
curry had it knocked away we picked up
by Green back into Stephanie shot but
one in
rebound chase to retrieve by Chris Paul
that's just hustle always staples in he
tried to get it away it's picked up by
Green here comes my goodness rebound by
Thompson try these three right into
harden count it and the foul three for
four already he's got eight points green
catches
after the baby green with the ball pen
drives inside delays and David
that was beautiful Seth guarding Steph
gets the pass to draymond rain finds
Livingston and Livingston floats it up
and in I love the face in which draymond
Green is playing with the glass misses
draymond green another rebound
pushing once again finds Iguodala
draymond greens energy and pushing the
pace critical for Golden State and
they've cut a 15-point deficit to 10
draymond Green final seconds drives lamp
it's good at the buzzer
they'll review it but it looks like he
got it off let's take a peek draymond
Green down the lane clearly off in time
what an impact from Meyers Leonard once
again here in the first half draymond
Green throws it in we've seen this
plenty of times this series especially
here draymond Green pushing the
basketball and making play
[Music]
Thompson's green the finish nice syrup
and klay Thompson five to shoot back to
curry
draymond Green tries to three it's good
draymond Green drills to three and :
state goes up by four timeout portland
guys running him he sees draymond Green
all by himself
and the all-time competitive steps in
rhythm stairs down the bench
what a play
[Music]
Goga China give the wall out of
Leonard's hands Leonard gets away pass
inside goes to see a comply green curry
comes off Green Drive goes inside layer
[Music]
siakam double-teaming stone hurry that's
a two-pointer bad pass stolen by Lowery
greeted pursuit Lowery up Jimbo green
water rejection his pocket picks it up
Kyle Lowry trying to create a foul uses
wisdom waits until he elevates that says
get it out of here not on my watch
[Music]
[Applause]
curry rifles a pass to draymond Green
for the bucket winner throws it up with
C Ockham's tough pitching he has to
throw it away
Thompson laundry what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content